[Musique]
la question était de savoir quelle
journée passerait gérald darmanin rôle
lendemain de cette réunion de crise à
l'elysée où le chef de l'état ici de
dollars cadres et au lendemain du recul
sur l'article 24 de la loi sécurité
globale une réunion de près de deux
heures pendant laquelle le président de
la république a fait preuve de fermeté
la situation dans laquelle vous m'avez
mis aurait pu être évité je veux garder
l'ordre républicain la liberté l'unité
et la concorde
en tant que président de la république
je suis garant de cet alliage entre
liberté et ordre et je ne veux pas
passer d'un côté ou de l'autre
on a un pouvoir solitaire dumky risée du
président de la république qui on l'a vu
dans tout ce quinquennat a humilié les
maires humilié les corps intermédiaires
des syndicats ils maintenant ils
humilient sa majorité présidentielle est
fait pour l'article 24 puisque ses
intérêts cela la france entière je pense
que la majorité a été assez clair la
majorité va réécrire l'article 24 dans
le cadre de du parlement et notamment
des travaux du groupe majoritaire
ça avance alors j'espère que c'est pas
une technique d'enfumage c'est à dire
que je dise que vous l'entendez pas
arriver finalement ch comme le chien est
un people are you top tout sur ses
pattes ça mais il faudrait de vigilance
comme l'article 24
ils disent qu'ils veulent le réécrire
darmanin c'est le premier commandant oui
je fais de pompier pyromane
c'est qu'il est dans cette politique
spectacle il été choisi pour pour
représenter un carnet en vue des futures
échéances électorales
une droite dure musclé et qu'ils
puissent pomper les voix du front
national
la vérité c'est que les choix que vous
avez faits ont installé un climat
désastreux les français s'interrogent
sur l'emploi de la force publique sur
les instructions données sur la
stratégie d'utilisation des forces de
l'ordre
j'avais plus l'impression d'être au café
du commerce que à la commission des lois
pour l'audition du ministre de
l'intérieur parce que nous n'avons
absolument rien appris
avons eu droit aux citations de sa
grand-mère de son père georges brassens
renaud léo ferré ailleurs tout à l'heure
monsieur falorni a dit les sept péchés
capitaux de la police non ce sont des
sept péchés capitaux me semble t'il du
ministère de l'intérieur
ça a été la suppression d'effectifs
monsieur le député ça a été la
suppression de l'encadrement
intermédiaire
on a un président de la république dont
le mentor politique aujourd'hui et
nicolas sarkozy on a un ministre de
l'intérieur qui idolâtrent nicolas
sarkozy mais tout ce que nous payons
aujourd'hui c'est la politique
sécuritaire de nicolas sarkozy a été un
fiasco absolu
malheureusement en 15 ans en quinze ans
le seul député
je crains que la question étant
tellement importante que chacun peut se
regarder dans la glace hier matin
j'étais sur bfm tv et j'ai accusé à
juste titre bande son à l'appui j'accuse
et bfm tv d'avoir lors d'un reportage
dit je cite un article restreindrait la
liberté de filmer point une loi
liberticide selon les manifestants moi
ce qui m'intéressait c'est le
restreindre la liberté de films laissez
nous travailler sans attendre le 20
janvier date d'une probable réouverture
des restaurants
c'est le cri du coeur de ces
professionnels de la région nantaise
à la sortie de mon studio du studio de
bfmtv je croise le journaliste bruce
toussaint qui me dit bonjour avec un
grand sourire qui se garde bien de le
dire ce qu'ils me réserve qui aurait pu
me laisser un droit de parole voire même
le droit de débat sur le plateau puisque
ce monsieur prend beaucoup parti pour un
journaliste moi aussi je prends parti
des restaurateurs bien sûr mais pour la
première fois dans leur sillage leurs
fournisseurs ils sont loueur de
vaisselle vendeur de boissons ou
spécialiste de l'animation
[Musique]
oh
quelques heures après j'en sois l'appel
du patron de bfm tv
je pensais qu'il l'appelait pour
s'excuser il a appelé pour me fustiger
comme si j'étais son employé il a le feu
qui vous appeler monsieur fogiel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]